my name is jay lopez and i'm the owner
of kleenex
today i'm going to be walking you
through how we clean the kitchen exhaust
system in a restaurant
the purpose of a kitchen exhaust system
is to extract the fumes from a kitchen
in a commercial setting
in order to remove grease you have to
understand grease what holds the oil
together it's the fat and once the first
layer is up it becomes a magnet and it
attracts more and more and more
everything is clean from top to bottom
you will start cleaning the fan first
we're using a high-end degreaser with a
little potassium hydroxide and sodium or
dioxide those two chemicals combine
create miracles and destroying the fat
in the grease in our case we time it
somewhere between 10 to 15 minutes
once we see that the grease starts to
melt at that point we know we need to
apply hot water and remove it because
anything longer at that point is going
to start to destroy the metal
once the fan has been cleaned the next
step would be the dock that's the part
that connects the fan to the hood
this level is considered extreme that
was a fire waiting to happen
i would say this is about a year worth
of grease it all depends on the volume
of cooking if this is a moderate cooking
this is about a year's worth of grease
that's a lot
the duck is clean in a few different
steps
during this process we use a tool made
by guardian this tool is known as the
easy magnetic duct scraper it has
magnets set into the tool and the razor
blade on each side
once it's clinched to the dock it is
manually moved forward and backwards
until the grease is removed
and backward method assures that the
grease buildup will be removed from both
sides
you'll go from the yellow color
all the way into the black when it's in
the black level that's an extreme level
that means that the system has not been
properly maintained
in these types of designs we'll use duct
spinners and duct brushes the top
spinner is designed to self-rotate
within a protective cage and spray water
at high speed which this large buildup
from the metal duct
we use a combination of a foaming agent
and a degreaser the foam is used as a
delivering agent and allows the
degreaser to stay in contact with the
grease for a longer period if foam was
not used the degreaser would drip off
the grease
the next step would be the hood and the
filters
see the filters are your first line of
defense
what the filters is doing is holding
back key
and it's holding back most of that
grease when the filters no longer can
hold the grease and once that grease
starts getting heat and melting
you have the potential of that grease
dropping into your food and at that
point it's a health issue i've seen
restaurants been shut down by the health
department for not cleaning their hood
i've seen restaurants been shut down by
the fire marshal for not maintaining
their heads
we take precaution in protecting the
area from contamination we use two
layers of plastic sheeting in order to
protect the appliances from coming in
contact with any chemical
the second layer of plastic sheeting is
wrapped around the hood and then a
funnel is created
the funnel is used to drain the chemical
grease and water into the plastic
containers
[Music]
the plastic sheeting also serves as a
protective barrier and preventing the
chemical from coming in contact with the
food preparation area
once we're completed and the plastic
sheeting is removed we'll conduct a
fresh water wipe down and recommend to
the client that they do the same prior
to preparing any food
according to nfpa 96 which is the agency
that regulates this industry the
frequency of cleanings depends on the
style of cooking you're conducting and
the frequency of cooking for example if
you cook with solid fuel solid fuel is
basically cooking with charcoal those
are 30-day mandatory cleanings because
they produce a lot more grease and the
ambers that come from the solid fuel can
ignite the grease
if you're an occasional cooking facility
those would be a year
you